[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or is that for think with Dear John and
Hank it's a comedy podcast where two
brothers answer your questions give me
two BC advice and bring you all the
week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon John yes what did the patient
say when the doctor said that his brain
had lost all memory of 1980s music what
Oh No what's the cure first off I would
like to State for the record that the
cure are still a band so yeah point a
little bit offended as somebody who
loved the cure in 1991 that they would
be associated only with the 80s the cure
have been ongoing concerned Hank since
1976 they're a year older than I am so
that's a great point that's a good point
you've poked a good ol plot hole in my
dad joke Hank I have the most wonderful
good news of all time oh okay all right
Hank I'm just gonna read you a headline
from the Dallas Morning News
Texas grandma kills 12-foot Gator , says
she's finally avenged her miniature
horse I think it is the rare story where
the story is even better than the
headline the woman's name is Judy
Cochran she is the mayor of a town
called Livingston Texas and she killed a
12-foot 580 pound alligator with a
single shot oh that was in a pond and
then she blamed for the murder of her
beloved miniature horse what so so she's
she she blamed it is like how did her
horse die are we not sure did it die of
being like a afraid of an alligator oh
no it died of being eaten by an
alligator but I don't know for sure that
it was the same Ally
it might have been a different Gator
okay so I have has has Judy cut because
she seems pretty
you know legit yeah she cut this
alligator open to check and see if there
were any hooves in there
oh no the alligator ate the miniature
horse three years ago judy has been and
has been desperately trying to avenge
the death of her miniature horse ever
since and you should see the picture
saying she is just absolutely delighted
that's some Princess Bride stuff right
there my name is inigo montoya prepare
to die my name is Judy I'm the mayor of
this town and you ate my miniature horse
prepare to die Gator that ate my
miniature horse had six fingers and I
can't help but notice that you too sir
alright well thank you for the very good
news John I'm happy for Judy and I'm
glad the miniature horse has been
avenged though I have somewhat sad for
the alligator involved you got to do
what you got to do as a 12-foot Gator in
Livingston Texas but we've got questions
we need to get to John important
questions like this one from Emma who
asks dear Hank and John I am a 20 year
old college student who has just had her
first peanut butter and jelly sandwich
they are amazing who knew like literally
everyone Emma now that I am started
making myself Phoebe and Jay is quite
regularly I'm like wondering what the
best way to do it is do I peanut butter
both sides or just one do I put peanut
butter around the edges to hold the
jelly in PB and yay Emma I mean there's
I've only ever done it one way I also
love PB and J's it's really about like
getting that good fluffy soft white
bread around the edges that that really
makes it for me and having a craving for
one right now but like there's only one
way to do this right is that my
overthinking things yeah you put peanut
butter on one piece of bread and jelly
on the other piece of bread you do have
to get the percentage yeah right you
gotta have the correct ratio but once
you do that Emma you're good the only
thing I'd say is that there has been a
recent innovation in the field of peanut
butter and jellies that I highly
recommend
called an Uncrustables I've not tried
this I've had them suggested to me a
number of times by people who are very
passionate
Uncrustables fans like the way I feel
about Uncrustables is the way that I
hope someone anywhere feels about me
some like like they want to they want to
heat you up take you out of the freezer
just like completely consume you as if
you are a miniature horrible foot Gator
someday I want to feel the way 12-foot
Gator feels about Judy's miniature horse
is it possible that the miniature horse
just ran away and the Gator has been
unjustly blamed yeah yeah but like also
I feel like probably Judy knows what
she's talking about I know lots of
people are opposed to Uncrustables for
various reasons but I'll tell you when I
go to the Indy 500 every year I pack a
12 pack of frozen Uncrustables and buy
lap 80 they are nice and warm and I eat
oh you just let them you just let them
thaw out yeah yeah I used them to help
cool my beers I've been around lap 80
they're no longer ice now they're food
okay I'm looking at Uncrustables now and
I want to see how they're manufactured
oh I assume that they're made by cutting
off all of the crust is definitely a
stamp I think there's a stamp that comes
down and stamps it out yeah sneak peek
the Uncrustables that looks like a
factory what happens to all the crusts
do you think somewhere else in the world
Hank there's like a community that loves
only crusts and so now Smuckers sells
Uncrustables here in the United States
but then somewhere else they sell crust
opposed no no John I think I think that
it's the United States of America and so
they just they just put it in a bin and
and give it to the chickens like that's
true it's almost definitely the case I
would love to go see and Uncrustables
factory and I do want to know what
happens to the crust when they when they
industrially stamped these peanut butter
and jelly sandwiches out of giant sheets
of bread all I know is that they're
flipping delicious John did you know
that the Jim Schmucker company is
manufacturing a new
plant in Longmont Colorado that will
make Uncrustables it's scheduled to be
completed in 2019 it's great to know
that Smuckers is planning for the
Uncrustables on alright Hank this next
question comes from Mary who writes dear
John and Hank this year my high school
is offering free vaccines for flu season
now there are obviously a bunch of pros
in this situation vaccines are important
for keeping you healthy it's convenient
because it's happening at my school it's
free but there is one con I hate shots
mmm I know it's just a little prick but
it's like I can feel all the antigens
flowing into my bloodstream and then you
feel all numb afterwards and the nurses
look at you like you're a freakin
five-year-old and just about everything
about vaccines makes my skin crawl
do you have any tips or tricks to help
me cope with shots or science that can
reassure me
it may not be Christmas but I'm still
Mary Mary I I think one is is how much
better it's gotten and so I try to
remind myself that back in the day like
needles were bigger and thicker and like
rougher like at the microscopic level
and so shots used to hurt much worse
than they do now and I just think about
all the people who had to get shots that
were worse than the shots I had to get
that's helpful I also think it's helpful
to remind yourself how much it sucks
getting the flu and you're not like
guaranteeing yourself to not experience
that misery but you are decreasing your
chances of experiencing that misery and
maybe even more importantly you're
decreasing the chances that other people
who are extremely vulnerable to death
from the flu are going to experience
that death it's true and that really
helps me out when it comes to getting my
flu shot because I also don't love
needles I don't love shots but I do love
slightly increasing the chances that
people in my community will survive when
otherwise they might have died another
thing I'd say is like repetition like
doing the thing eventually it becomes
less unpleasant often times this has
happened for me like eight years ago I
started taking a medication or I had to
get my blood taken pretty frequently and
when when I started doing that it was I
really hated it and I dreaded it every
time and now I show up and I'm like so
up Steve and he's like right armor left
and then it's like washing the dishes
like it's
what I wouldn't do in any given day but
it's not like something that I super
dread John I have another question for
you here comes from Paige who asks dear
Hank and John my roommate and I disagree
on a fundamentally important question
that could change our futures forever is
you two a boyband
she says yes they are a group of men who
started the band as boys but I
completely disagree it's you two they
aren't like in sync or the Backstreet
Boys they're you two I'm made out of
trees Paige wait wait
I feel like Paige buried the lead a page
of paper I thought that yeah all right
it's not literal yeah well it's funny
that you should ask this question Paige
because Robert Smith the lead singer of
The Cure formed the Cure when he was 17
years old huh and several other members
of the Cure I believe were also
technically children when they began
curing way back in the mid 1970s I would
argue that the cure are not a boy band
even though they were once composed of
all boys yeah I feel like I feel like
there's a pretty specific definition of
boy band and this it isn't a band made
of boys it is a band that was
manufactured by adults by putting boys
Aiden - like by recruiting boys to be in
a band correct
like the monkeys were a boy band because
they were manufactured the Beatles were
not a boy band because they met and
formed a band together yet to me it's a
central fact of the boy band story that
the boy band was formed by some usually
exploitative adult trying to extract
value from these young people's talents
and and also intrinsic to the boy band
story is the eventual rejection of that
that Overlord and then being able to go
off and and be creative from out under
the shadow of the of the created
institution and then later coming back
into the created institution and be like
we are the Backstreet Boys and we will
tour together because we are people
right and we can do that and we love
our fans and we love making things and
on now I want to go see a back boys back
boys band concert sounds like a great
Backstreet Boys cover band yeah it's
funny how even though many different boy
bands have lived that boy band narrative
I am not yet tired of it like I can't
help it I love to see America build a
celebrity up tear that celebrity down
and then build them back up again
alright I think we got another question
this one comes from gene who writes to
you John and Hank how am I supposed to
behave when people are singing happy
birthday to me I mean I have had 38
birthdays and I still can't tell you I
guess you just sit there like with a
dumb smile on your face and you're like
thanks everyone for paying attention to
me could you sing this song slightly
faster well I have two observations
about this Hank first almost every time
in life when you feel like people are
looking at you and paying attention to
you and gauging your every facial
expression you're wrong and you just
need to calm down and remind yourself
that it's okay and everyone is obsessed
with themselves and not thinking about
you but when people are singing happy
birthday to you you can't reassure
yourself that way like they are looking
at you and you do have to like try to
put on a face that is appropriate for
the situation that you find yourself in
and whenever I have that problem the
problem that people are actually looking
at me I I turn to one mentor and do you
know who that is Hank no it's the Queen
of England the Queen of England always
has people looking at her and so she is
incredibly good at making a face that
says I acknowledge you thank you for
acknowledging me and let the festivities
continue so like your eyebrows are a
little up but not very up and your eyes
are fairly open and your smile is
pleasant but not large and you're just
like hey everyone's doing this this is
nice and and thank you and I agree that
we all should be celebrating me in
moment I am right there with you good
job me I lived a year again that's right
that's exactly right just Google the
Queen of England and paint that face
onto your face and you'll be good that
sounds like a makeup challenge No happy
birthday I painted the Queen of England
face onto my face that's the only way I
can feel comfortable while you guys are
singing to me you show up to your
birthday party and people are like you
you do look a year older Wow
been a while since I seen you this nice
question is a science question so it's
just for me dear Hank and John why is it
that when there's a black frame and a
movie or TV show or whatever for example
the opening scene of Fellowship of the
Ring my computer screen looks different
than when it's just turned off isn't
black just the absence of light why not
have those pixels not emit light nothing
rhymes with Kirsten do you know the
answer to the questions ah I don't know
it's because the pixels don't emit light
the pixels change the color of the light
as it passes through so in a laptop
screen or you know any any almost any
any any modern display it's just a
uniform sheet of LEDs or some other
light emitting thing behind this film
and it can only be on or off some of
them can have intensities of brightness
in different areas and that like that
allows for deeper blacks but usually
it's just we are this is just a giant
like lamp that I'm looking at that is
shining at me and then the thing that
lays on top of it changes the color of
the light as it passes through mm-hmm
and so black is is the the liquid
crystal display trying to block as much
of the light as it can but that light is
still there behind it
Oh interesting it's kind of a metaphor
that light is always there John
but sometimes it is trying to be blocked
by the intro screen of the Lord of the
Rings movie
exactly I don't even have to explain it
it's a perfectly self-explanatory this
next question comes from a Liana who
writes dear Shawn and Hank why do people
hate raisins
I've always enjoyed raisins but it seems
that very few people enjoy them as much
as I do what don't people like about
them do you guys like raisins or hate
them you know what I think about raisins
John I think there's a lot about a lot
of dried fruit in general is that like
once upon a time it was hard to find
something tasty and sweet and now yeah
it's everywhere I could just go get a
twizzler I could have a fudge round
right now I could just drink pure sugar
water for 50 cents a can and so back in
the day a raisin was like oh my god
there's so much sweetness in one place
and now we're like look at this trash
ball that basically is trying to be a
twizzler but failing okay I have two
problems with everything you just said
first off yeah I I don't understand why
you're celebrating Twizzlers which are
literally the worst candy changeit of
Jelly Belly or yes M&M or whatever you
like Oh anything is acceptable except
for Twizzlers which aren't sweet they
taste like no Twizzlers taste like you
told someone without tastebuds to make
something that tastes like strawberry
sweetness
I like Twizzlers and we're and and we're
just gonna have to agree to disagree
okay well you're objectively wrong but
the other thing is that you're
objectively wrong about raisins what do
you mean I'm not saying they're actually
trash balls I'm just saying that people
like nowadays it's just too easy to get
sweet stuff and so we're like opening a
raisin cookie I could have a chocolate
chip cookie so my son recently had to do
a project for school where he was
learning about facts and opinions really
everyone should take course a difference
between facts and opinions and how you
know that facts are facts and opinions
are opinions and as part of that he had
to write out of fact about raisins and
an opinion about raisins and his fact
was raisins or dried grapes and his
opinion was raisins are terrible
like why what is it because it because
they're trash balls and you could just
have a chocolate chip right now yeah I
was like what's wrong with raisins and
he was like they're disgusting and I was
like what's disgusting about them and he
was like they just taste like dried
grapes and I was like well I mean I mean
you're not wrong that's correct good
good so his argument is that the grape
is a good fruit and since we live in a
world of abundance where we don't have
to dry our fruit to make it last longer
that we should just eat grapes but I
quite like raisins and by the way Aliana
don't let anybody tell you what kind of
foods to like except when it comes to
Twizzlers
we got a question John it's from Ilsa
who asks dear Hank and John my friend is
a problem that is sort of my fault and I
need some dubious advice it started when
she told me that there was a boy in her
orchestra who she randomly had the
number 4 and she wasn't sure why so
she's got a phone number doesn't know
why she has a phone number but he plays
cello and is apparently pretty cute and
she asked me what to do I have a cute
cello players phone number and I need to
know what to do so Elsa said that she
should text thank you for signing up for
the daily cello pun service or something
like that and then text him cello puns
she started this service which is just
for one person and all was great but she
has run out of puns Google is not
helping and we need you two to save this
fake subscription and give us more puns
Ilse John can I go ahead and question
else's strategies yeah I think I guess I
just don't understand contemporary
courtship because I thought that when
you had a kind of interest in someone
you would talk to them maybe via text
messages but but talk to them as
yourself not as a cello pun service an
imaginary as an imaginary service that
he didn't sign up for but apparently
hasn't unsubscribed from so that's yeah
no I mean the good news is he likes it I
think it's time to end the cello pun
service and send out a message that says
like hi this is the
the cello pun service but the beginning
of talking to me an actual human being
who you met once and gave probably gave
your number two and I am wondering if
perhaps you would be interested in a if
you will a string duet you got a kind of
pun in there also the other good news is
that I have tweeted in the meantime
while John was doing that that I needed
some cello puns for love and I've gotten
a hundred and six replies and do you
want to hear some of them John
desperately you could have your friend
text to the cute cello player Netflix
and cello or when life gets you
lemonades you can make limoncello
I don't care that our families are
against our union let's chill out
together she all right that's it I'm
calling it it's the end of the cello
puns Ilsa this has to stop both for me
and for this poor for cello oh god oh
god it's it won't stop it won't end that
we have it the next question the next
question comes from I don't know who I
just have to I can't I why do I hate
puns so much something about g-strings
nope nothing about g-strings this next
question comes from I can't find one we
have so many questions I know that's why
I'm panicked
I'm gonna blind panic I can't even look
okay I found one this next question
comes from Emily who writes Dear John
and Hank I recently started a new job at
a marketing firm where I primarily write
their blog this is great because I
graduated college with a bachelor's in
writing but it isn't great because I
don't have any experience in marketing
which is the topic of all these blogs I
have to write as people who often give
advice on topics you know nothing about
what tips do you have for someone who
has to give advice on a topic they know
nothing about pumpkins and penguins
Emily I like it Emily take a lesson from
Hank green and just sound confident
whenever you talk that's right that's
right no one really knows what marketing
is Emily that's a great point
that's a great point and and like really
what marketing is is trying to get
people to pay attention to you so
anytime you are blogging you are doing
marketing you're trying to get people
that you're marketing your marketing is
what you're doing what I would do in
this situation is I would ask some of
the people you work with if you can
interview them about their areas of
expertise because then it's a chance to
get a blog post oh and you learn
something about marketing along the way
that's that's wonderful John high-five
so it's like that's such a good idea
that's like so antithetical to the
spirit of the question where we're
giving good advice on something we know
nothing about that shouldn't have been
possible I mean I would submit that I
know way more about marketing novels
than about writing them but your point
is well-taken they do get you involved
in the marketing process John I have
been surprised by how many times my
about the people I work with whose jobs
are like head of publicity or marketing
have been like what should we do yeah
well they want to work with you in a way
that makes sense for you yeah I keep
forgetting that we are about to go on
tour for your first novel this is crazy
how did this happen I realized that you
spent years and years writing the book
and that's how it happened but I am so
excited to go on tour for not my thing
maybe that's why I'm feeling more
stressed about it because like it's my
thing and I feel very responsible for
the quality of the stage show which I
have spent the last week designing and I
think is very good but also it's sort of
complicated because I've been wanting to
make it quite good and that makes me
more stressed because it's like if it's
not good I worked pretty hard on a thing
that nobody likes which reminds me that
this podcast is brought to you by the
absolutely remarkable thing booked or
which tickets are available right now
and probably still available for all the
new york show which is happening
tomorrow when this podcast comes out and
and also a lot of other places that
we'll be going to and lastly today's
podcast is brought to you by the an
absolutely remarkable thing tote bag and
sticker literally available right now at
dftba.com it's really good I designed
them both
myself so I guess I shouldn't have said
it's really good in that very confident
way but here I am I'm me ya know just
keep being yourself Inc I love I love
your confidence I also love that when
you are under immense stress and there
is a lot going on in your life your
reaction is to just do more so you're
like I'm gonna make a bunch of videos
I'm gonna design some merch for my book
I'm gonna plan a complicated like stage
show with 17 costume changes and lots of
audio and visual cues that I'm sure
won't be problematic at all and I'm
gonna it's great like my response to
being under a lot of stress is to like
turtle response where I'm like I bet if
I hide under my desk no one will find me
I did have that that impulse the other
day for the first time where I was like
my neighbor is working on his sighting
like he's nailing up siding right now
and I'm like I should just go over and
help him help him put up his siding
because like I could do that I know I
know how to use a hammer and then no one
would be able to find me they'd be like
where's Hank
they wouldn't everything I was on on my
neighbor's roof like tap and down
shingles ya know I mean I literally did
a version of that after I came home from
the Turtles all the way down to her I
was like that was weird and really
intense and I think that I'm going to
demolish this small building in the
backyard of my house and I'm going to
use the bricks from it to make a path
and I did that sounds like my area of
expertise I worked like 60 hours a week
on that path for like a month and then
at the end of it I remember I put the
last brick down and I looked up and I
was like that was an excellent use of my
time like a genuinely excellent use of
my one brief flicker of consciousness
and all the time I walk on that path now
it takes exactly one minute to walk the
path and I walk on that path now and I
think like oh what a great month that
was so anyway when you get back from
tour Hank I'm sure there's going to be a
lot of
equivalents to that that you can turn to
it I want to but what you're probably
gonna do is like write another book make
600 Hank channel videos and design some
merch yeah I seem more unlikely this
next question comes from Delfino who
asks dear Hank and John I recently
graduated from college and I just
accepted an internship at a great
company for the next six months I really
like working here but I really want to
know how do I make friends with the
people I work with they're all in their
mid to late 20s and the place is super
creative and relaxed every day I do my
very best to get all the work I'm given
done and to try to learn all the
software that I need to work with in my
free time but what I really want to know
is how do I become part of their
conversations and their jokes whenever
I'm with my boss it seems like the only
thing we could talk about is the weather
what's your advice for an intern trying
to make a lasting impression sincerely
the Oracle of Delphi nah I think this is
hard I don't have a good answer I mean I
guess you need to like know how social
interaction happens at your office and
and like in any situation where you're
coming into an existing social space
like there won't be an immediate place
for you and it's been created without
you and so there's institutional
knowledge like inside jokes and like
just culture and values that you're not
aware of and so this is necessarily hard
and I think coming into it thinking how
am I gonna make a lasting impression
it's probably not the right way to like
secure if you like this job like that
might not be the right mindset to be in
like how do I make everyone remember me
is like there are lots of ways to make
them remember you that will not make
people want to work with you right so
like definitely be focused on like
making life easier for your co-workers
try to figure out like what what their
challenges are and commiserate with them
on those challenges and also help them
out with those challenges but also where
are the places and times when social
like socializing happens you know are
there meetings that are fairly small
that are also pretty relaxed and people
are you know not just talking about work
but also sort of building company
culture and can you be in those meetings
can you like make a reason for yourself
to be in a meeting like that
and also just accepting that like it's
gonna take a while for you to become a
part of and to understand the culture
and values of the place where you work
and that is just a part of being new at
a place and and six months is a pretty
actually a pretty short time to try to
get all that done in so don't you know
don't don't put too much pressure on
yourself if it doesn't feel like at the
end of the six months like you've become
like an intrinsic part of the company
because it does take a while yeah I
would focus on being helpful
I think that's by far the biggest thing
you can do in an internship is crush the
internship part of the internship and
the interpersonal stuff should accompany
that rather than the interpersonal stuff
leading it right and I think there might
be sometimes a little bit too much in
our minds we think like oh I'm gonna
like I'm gonna keep my job because
everyone likes me but that's not really
how it works especially sort of a
modern-day business like you keep your
job because you're doing a good job of
it alright I go what ask you this
question from Abby who writes Dear John
and Hank a couple months ago I got a pet
frog and I named him Hank
ah Hank that is very sweet now Hank is
dead okay with Hank was thank eaten by
an alligator can we avenge him was there
[Laughter]
no Hank died due to organ failure and I
was wondering if I should get another
frog and named him John or if John would
rather share his name with another
animal your favorite NCIS character Abbi
that name specific sign-off is sort of
lost on me and I've never seen the
program yeah that's uh it may very well
be my favorite NCIS character I cannot
really come up like it can't conjure a
visual image of any of them there's a
man Raja and a woman who is too old to
have pigtails it's it's the it's the
latter all right Abby here's the deal I
would love it if you named a pet after
me it would be one of the great joys of
my life to know that somewhere there is
somebody who thinks enough of my work to
name their pet after me I don't want a
frog because I'm concerned that it will
die after just two months of organ
failure
yeah what I want is pretty simple and
pretty straight
word Abby I want you to get a miniature
horse and I want you to name it John
[Laughter]
that sounds like a big ask
nope I gotta be honest Abby I'm gonna
need you to acquire some pasture land
but not too but not too much you also
can't have one miniature horse John they
need friends yeah Hank Hank the other
miniature horse okay I'm in now I like
it my lord
this is cute John and Hank the miniature
horses in wherever you live Abby and if
you live in a city don't worry just buy
the house next to you tear it down and
put in some pasture land
yeah there's small horses it's fine if
you live near like a bayou or some
swampland do be concerned about that
though this is a new concern of mine but
it is a legitimate concern that Bennett
sure horses are Gator food oh my god
have you seen how small miniature horses
are they can be really small oh my god
these are the cutest things I have ever
seen in my whole life Oh God
uh I might need 200 they're adorable oh
my god and now it all makes sense now
you understand how an alligator could
totally eat that especially because they
don't look like they would be
particularly good at anything oh and if
somebody ate one of my miniature horses
I would be so angry my anger would burn
with the fire of a thousand suns your
anger would burn with at least one
shotgun I bet oh I I absolutely I would
find it I'm looking at a picture of a
baby
riding a miniature horse and the
miniature horse is nose snuggling with a
Clydesdale and I might die man and if
somebody ate that miniature horse if an
alligator ate that miniature horse you
can you better believe that I would hire
someone to kill that alligator and if a
bane egg that was the best joke I have
ever told and you didn't laugh I don't
did you must not have heard me I was
finding the picture I was looking for
the picture I found it and if an
alligator ate that Clydesdale I would
definitely just let the alligator take
over the world yeah it's in charge now
[Laughter]
congratulations you are president I vote
for you oh man I'd love to do one of the
one of the bad things about being a
human Hank is that you can't run a bunch
of really high quality simulations about
what would happen if you did X or Y and
so you make decisions without having all
of the information that you need to make
the decision yep but I would love to run
a simulation where in the year 2020 we
all just elect an alligator to be
President and we see what happens yes I
would also 100% like to see the results
of that simulation I would not like to
see the results of that in a way that I
could not escape from it right exactly I
don't want to bet the farm on an
alligator president but I'm definitely
interested in an alligator president
Hank before we get to the all-important
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon I do
want to share one other email from a
listener named Jess so you might
remember in a recent episode we advised
someone who was attending a wedding and
was nervous about a bouquet throw to
just get in with everyone else but
intentionally not catch the bouquet
mm-hmm for those who are unaware there's
this weird tradition in at least
American weddings where the bride throws
her bouquet of flowers and whoever
catches that bouquet is supposed to be
the next person to get married anyway
Jess wrote in to say Dear John and Hank
in the last episode of the pod Hank
theorizes what would happen if no one
caught a bouquet at a wedding that exact
scenario has happened to me I was a
bridesmaid at a friend's wedding and as
a single lady I lined up for the bouquet
toss the bride gave a good backwards
toss and no one went for it
no one even jumped up and down in
excitement we all just stood there
awkwardly as the flowers flew through
the air and then the bouquet landed on
the floor for what felt like 30 seconds
until the bride said really and then it
last someone not me
the grudgingly shuffled forward a few
steps and picked it up the bright side
is that this is a humorous story that
the married couple can tell for years so
no worries Emily don't catch that
bouquet unless you darn well
- don't stress Jess and Hank we can't
share it because it has people's face in
it but it came with a picture the fish
read the picture it's one of those
magical things I've ever seen because
every first off the bouquet is almost on
the ground and all of it was like still
in the air but it's like a foot off the
ground
with their arms at their sides staring
at the bouquet as it falls they all got
their eyes right on it and they're like
I guess we're all just gonna stand here
because I don't want a bunch of flowers
to decide my future and a couple people
have looks of open disdain like the
young woman in the green dress she it
looks like it kind of might get close to
her and she's literally recoiling quick
she's like it's gonna bail toward me
what is it do I have to catch it what if
it just touches me and then the woman in
the black skirt she's looking like she's
holding one arm up to her heart and
she's looking at it like oh god no oh
God oh I think she's like nobody's going
for she has stood well to the side
because she's like I'm not gonna be
anywhere near that
but all the people who are a little bit
closer just like half smile yeah yeah
yeah oh man nobody wants that booze for
me oh god it's terrible so Hank AFC
Wimbledon have entirely new players but
somehow we don't have entirely new
results yesterday as we're recording
this Wimbledon played the swansea
under-21 team in the Football League
trophy which because under-21 teams from
the Premier League are now allowed to
play and it has become an absolute joke
we lost one nil but I would argue this
is good news because I don't want to
move out of the group in this I want to
be able to focus on competitions that
matter so in our most recent league game
we lost 3-2 to Scunthorpe it's just been
a real struggle and I'm worried I am
like officially worried I we really need
to get through this season still in the
third tier of English football because
next season midway through the year if
everything happens on schedule the new
stadium will open and that's going to be
such a huge moment
history of Wimbledon and I really really
really want us to be a third tier team
I'm trying to do my part by increasing
the sponsorship that we have by making
an absolutely remarkable thing the
training kit sponsor for AFC Wimbledon
but of course sponsors can only do so
much so wimbledon are struggling along
hopefully form will improve soon okay I
mean any time you guys score I feel good
like it was that it was that like that
goal drought that made me the most
worried yeah that like the month of
November when they had to cancel the
goal of the month celebration due to
having had no goals yeah so I didn't
like that and I feel like if you're if
you're losing two three basically that's
a like in most situations where you
score two goals in a soccer game you win
yeah is that right yeah that is probably
correct or at least time yeah so I so I
just feel like like situations like that
you know it's just it's just went down
to bad luck and and so if we have had
some bad luck in the beginning of the
season and hopefully things will turn
around
Hank I am anxiously awaiting the news
from Mars because I've been I'm worried
that the the death knell the official
death knell is going to come any day now
well we're not gonna talk about
opportunity today because there is the
there isn't any new news I've okay that
it's all up for the the sort of path
that we must take and necessary going
through the emotions waiting to you know
hear back but they're the the news that
I'm I'm reporting today is a survey so a
survey was carried out in August on
adults in the United Kingdom and and the
survey was supposed to be representative
of people who will be adults in the UK
in 2026 and it found that of the people
who will be of age to go to Mars in 2026
now that that's going to happen but
fingers crossed 50% of men and 30% of
women would be happy to go on a return
trip to Mars I feel like this is a very
high percentage and the people have not
been correctly informed as to what this
entails totally and yeah
also there currently many of them are
currently like 12 that's true through a
number of them are children and as for a
one-way trip 40% of men said that they
would definitely or probably want to go
on a one-way trip to Mars and 20% of
women first of all this just makes me
less optimistic about men but but but
very high percentages in both cases I
mean like saying yes I want to go die on
Mars that's a lot of people saying yes
yeah I think that in addition to having
to die on Mars there's the other problem
which is that life on Mars for years or
decades would likely be very difficult
yeah well I mean that's it that's an
interesting thing to me like people who
like kind of want to sign up to do
something very hard even though there
are lots of very hard things you could
do right here on earth but to feel like
you're doing something really awful but
it's exceptional at the same time and
like that thing is really interesting to
me where people are like and it's
entirely in in your own mind right like
doing terrible difficult unpleasant
manual labor on Mars is the same action
as doing it on earth but no one wants to
do it on earth but I think a lot of
people would sort of feel like more okay
about doing it on Mars because it has
that that layer of like you know like
doing a thing that has never been done
and also I'd like potentially setting up
humans for this new adventure yeah even
if you're not going to sort of enjoy the
good parts of the adventure yeah one of
the things I like about humans is that
we are explorers we can't kind of can't
help but try to find what's on the other
side of things like we're just
incredibly curious and I like that about
us I like that we're willing to let our
curiosity take us to risky dangerous
places and in a way that's why we've
become such a successful species I mean
the reason humanity spread across the
planet in the first place was because we
were curious in a way
other species of the genus Homo worked
yeah and and I do hope that it takes us
to Mars and I I am very I'm in awe of
the people who will sign up for that
because I'm not one cuz I I get pukey
going in elevators
ya know I'm also out on that but I do
hope I desperately hope that I live to
see the day when human beings first set
foot on Mars and that I am there to
celebrate it with you like that is
something that I would fly to wherever
you are to see you see it poof that
makes me very nervous
well I mean you know it we would also
just be hanging out so you know if
everything no I just like the idea like
like just watching curiosity lanta made
me extremely nervous so exciting oh god
that was such a fun day yeah it really
was
yeah alright well Hank congratulations
on your book the book is an absolutely
remarkable thing that's both its title
and its description I'm so excited for
everybody to read it thanks for potting
with me Hank thanks to everybody for
listening this podcast is edited by
Nicholas Jenkins it's produced by
rosianna halse rojas and sheridan Gibson
our head of community and communications
is Victoria Bongiorno the music that
you're listening to right now and at the
beginning of the podcast is by the great
gunnarolla and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]
you